there's something wrong about nerds
being allowed on a rock star stage like
this nerds
yes but Google's latest announcements
weren't a rock star stage especially
when the amphitheater sits in the heart
of Silicon Valley Google made several
announcements of its annual show and
Tyler
io Conference and as expected the tech
giant's progress with artificial
intelligence is at the core of many of
its innovations the app-based okay
google voice interface has been around
for a while but now there's an improved
AI powered assistant that better
understands voice commands and Google
aims to go even further by building
digital assistants across a multitude of
apps and devices first there's Google
home it's a wireless speaker with a
built-in voice powered assistant and if
that sounds like Amazon echo it's
because it is it comes complete with
third-party partners for music podcasts
news or during dinner and even calling a
cab it's also pretty cute and you get to
pick your own color then there is a
l'heure it's a chat app with stickers
and cool interface tricks like the
ability to make your message bigger or
smaller to indicate excitement or lack
thereof but behind the scenes there's
some cool predictive tech you can book
movie tickets or make reservations
without even leaving map
Android n the next version of Google's
mobile OS is almost done and there are
gobs of new features software updates
now happens seamlessly in the background
just like Chromebooks
there's Vulcan 3d graphics to improve
games
there's better security better
notifications and better multitasking
with support for multiple open windows
at once it launches later this summer
but there's a beta quality release
candidate available now for Nexus
devices Google's launched daydream a
wide-ranging via platform that
encompasses everything Google's working
on with virtual reality and the company
is developing the next version of
Android with VR in mind
Google's also building headsets with
multiple partners too so expect more
this fall and finally there's a new
Android build for your wrist
Android wear 2.0 looks a lot cleaner
nicer for messaging there are smart
replies better handwriting recognition
and a new keyboard where apps can now
plug into Google fit so apps like Strava
can start tracking you as soon as you
start running no phone needed in fact
there's no phone requirement at all
Android wear watches work with our
tethering expect the new OS and new
wearables this fall